what Iowa has begun tonight is a
political revolution
I decided that you know no matter what
I'm going to go I'm going to rent a car
I'm gonna drive to Iowa I'm going
through whatever I can try to make him
win it's a grassroots movement you have
volunteers coming from all around
knocking door-to-door we worked hard we
were knocked on doors in the city and
there was a farm wood farm to farm
talking to people I could say I
personally got a few people after gertie
maybe 10 maybe 20 maybe 30 and I was
calling calling calling fun we've got
like so many volunteers you know the
Hillary officers doesn't have the
volunteer network that we have
I think what happened is people saw a
candidate that was actually pushing for
what they cared about and wouldn't
compromise I thought I would come out
here and here everyone say Oh Bernie
Sanders a socialist and he's not a real
American but what I actually heard from
a lot of people is that he's in the only
authentic person on the Democratic side
I think it's proof that the American
people really like can see like truth
and goodness in a candidate we're going
to take back the country again it not to
like be very similar to Donald Trump